so this talk
draws inspiration from two sources
uh the first is something this guy said
who is this guy
yell it out that's correct alex russell
wrote this
in a blog post a few months ago about
feature detection and ui sniffing and
all the stuff that he's
presumably talking about tomorrow and he
closed out the post
with this and i knew exactly what he was
talking about because i see
examples of moralized black and white
thinking in the javascript community
all the time i see it not so much at
conferences like these but i see it on
stack overflow
and in blog comments and on usenet
although i suppose that's what usenet is
for
but it worries me because ordinarily
developers realize that best practices
are highly situational
and that what works for someone who's
writing a node app
may not work for someone who's on the
client side team at facebook
uh and may not work for the guy who's
maintaining is
avagodalive.com
and in fact we see that same nuance in
other fields i've read several
introductory books
that that uh for several diverse topics
that have this idea that there are rules
and you should follow them at first but
over time you know you sort of learn the
purpose of the rule in the first place
and then you can break the rules if you
want
um that they sort of become guidelines
as you get wiser
george orwell understood it too he
realized that he couldn't write a
catch-all
set of guidelines for using something as
complicated as the english language
so he made sure that the reader knew
that the rules were less important than
the ideas behind them
and that's why i'm worried when i hear
people reciting commandments
we shouldn't treat coding practices like
morality
and we should be precise in our
tutorials
and in our evangelism in order to
discourage that kind of black and white
thinking the other inspiration was this
guy
who is this guy
say it louder it is donald glover and he
tweeted this
last year
and aside from being excellent advice in
its own right i think this is a great
way to frame a contrarian argument
because you can
you can attack any rule in this manner
and you're probably right
so let's treat this as my thesis
metaphorically i'm going to mount a
defense of shorts but
i'm not saying we should all wear shorts
all the time
in fact some some of us should never
wear shorts
ever at all so i suppose i'm saying that
some of us should maybe wear shorts more
often
this is the sub thesis of my talk that
code can be regulated
not through rules enforced by language
design
or by morality but by the evolution of
social customs
and so we should be less concerned about
what is right and wrong in best
practices than
about what is polite and impolite i
think that's a
far better way to talk about these
things because politeness has greater
situational
awareness than morality does morality
doesn't make
many exceptions for context like you can
kill a guy if he's trying to kill you
but really like but that's about it
and uh but as far as politeness people
understand that it depends greatly on
context
as is the case with best practices
so i want to approach the topic of
extending built-ins
from that angle and sort of look at the
past
the present and the future of it
prototype has been extending built-ins
for years
so let's go back to the beginning and
see where its ideas came from
it started out as a tiny collection of
convenience functions
version 1.0 of prototype was 104 lines
of code
of a size that you probably wouldn't
even bother putting on github these days
version 1.1 is was the first
version to feature an interesting piece
of code
that extends object.prototype it does so
for an arguably use
useful reason it's nice to be able to
merge two objects together but
if it has a pretty big downside i've
just defined an enumerable property on
all my objects so that means our
annoying or helpful method shows up in
all
four in loops so there are ways around
this
you can use has own property to check
whether the property belongs to the
object itself
or to its prototype and this is
crockford arguing for this very thing
raise your hand if you write all your
for loops like this
don't don't lie you're all on github i
can check
all right so nobody listened
or very few people listened five trolls
in the back listened apparently
um so there was just there was no chance
of this happening
and i know because crockford told us to
do it and we didn't do it
um for one thing safari 2.0 and below
didn't support has owned property and
that was important at the time
but also this is a major chore and
you've got to do it every single time
you write a foreign loop
and it's hard to convince people to opt
into a chore
it's easier to dictate what people
shouldn't do than what they should
eric arvidsson now of google and a
contributor to
ecmascript suggested a different
approach back in 2005.
he said we should just agree to be hands
off without with object.prototype
and this was this was easier to enforce
because there are far fewer people
who want to extend object.prototype than
there are people who want to use foreign
loops
so this is what we the community ended
up doing instead
but i find this fascinating this is how
he starts off the post it is not seldom
that you see people messing with
object.prototype it was apparently not
seldom
that in mid 2005 people were doing this
sort of thing
so i imagine the prototype wasn't the
only offender
and then one of the comments
um to the post explains that no it's
totally okay to add whatever you want to
object.prototype you just have to use
has zone property
and then you have to implement it um
in browsers that don't support it so if
you want to add n
methods to object.prototype you just
have to add n plus one and
you're totally fine um and it's
revealing because the comment assumes
that you
write all the code and i'm sure that was
true for the commenter but we were very
quickly moving toward
a model where most of the code that runs
on a page wasn't
written by the page's owner and the fact
that we were having this conversation in
the first place
shows that that this was sort of already
upon us because
no one we don't need to have
conversations about manners if we're all
if we're all hermits so between
1.3 and 1.4 prototype changed
it moved object.prototype.extend to
object.extend
if legend is to be believed this was
largely the work of dean edwards
as it was told to me dean emailed sam
steven and said sam stevenson
one day and said so i'm going to write a
blog post recommending against using
prototype
because it extends object.prototype i
really like prototype and i really don't
want to have to do that so
instead i hope you'll just change
prototype and sam did
and i think it was a good move i think
both dean and sam did the right thing
there
and as a result that was the first and
last time that prototype ever
touched object.prototype
of course prototype has extended other
built-in objects since the beginning
for a while the only method added to
arrays though was push
and only in environments where it didn't
exist like internet explorer five
but prototype 1.4 had innumerable
which had a lot of methods for iterating
over
arrays so in version 1.4
prototype went from adding nothing to a
readout prototype
except in explorer 5 to adding around
30 methods and that broke some code in
the in
in the wild and
there are a couple of odd legitimate use
cases for doing four
in on a raise people have argued for
sparse arrays um and using foreign on
those that you don't have to loop
through a bunch of undefined properties
but
most foreign usage in the wild was just
dumb
and most like most people were treating
arrays like hashes when they could just
as easily have used
objects and so i said so
five years ago i think um
i said that using arrays this has as
hashes is no more
reasonable than using string objects or
regular expression
objects or anything else as a hash
and it became the most popular thing
i've ever written but
so i wasn't even a prototype developer
back then
but buried in this article is the idea
that prototype
may not be for everyone
if someone had said to me you know i'd
love to use prototype but i've got dumb
third-party code on my page that does
four in
over arrays and i can't replace it
and i can't change it i i said i would
have said that sucks you should probably
use another framework
um prototype was never trying to conquer
the world it was
happy to be a love it or hate it kind of
thing there's one more area to cover
quickly in 1.5 we started adding things
to dom nodes
in general it made working with dom far
less painful
but it pushed prototype into a minefield
though we may not have realized it at
the time we could extend
elements cheaply in most browsers with
these with
our convenience methods but not in
ie because you weren't able to doc to
augment dom objects prototypes until
version 8.
so in explorer we had to copy them over
manually one by one as elements were
retrieved
and we tried to optimize this as much as
possible but it was still a huge
performance
bottleneck and it was a millstone around
our necks in the
selector engine wars we ran into other
problems too
over time it became clear and clear that
host objects behave in unpredictable
ways
and weren't converging on any sort of
common behavior
and it's because host objects by
definition don't have to abide by
any rules um and so we were stuck with
this approach for backward compatibility
but we decided the prototype 2.0
would have wrappers around dom nodes and
event objects instead of augmenting them
directly
uh a year ago kangax wrote the
definitive the definitive article about
this sort of thing
um and i agree with just about
everything he says in this article
and i would even agree that this was the
biggest mistake prototype ever made
but if i may segue out of prototype and
into general
best practices nicholas
zakis's article about not modifying
objects you don't own i think is also
relevant
and i see it referenced all over the
place and i have no quarrel with the
basic arguments
but let's apply this to built-ins don't
modify objects you don't own all right
who owns built-ins
we might say that the language owns
built-ins but then they're not
the most diligent of caretakers there
are things that we've needed for ages
like trim on strings or like
collection methods on arrays that we
were that
that got added very slowly over time
because the process of specification is
necessarily slow
and when i say i shouldn't modify that
object because i don't own it
i'm saying it's not my job to modify it
it's someone else's job and so if
something's not working right
in a third party library i'm using
i could monkey patch it to work the way
i want
but i should probably just file a bug
with the library maintainer because it's
their job to fix it
but nobody claims to provide this level
of service for built-ins
i think we all own built-ins i think
they're shared property
and as a result they have all the
upsides and downsides of shared property
it's mine to use and i'm trusted to use
it in a way that doesn't mess it up for
other people
so rules regarding shared property are
just as much about courtesy as they are
as they are about law so we come back to
this idea of social customs
and code relying not on the language's
rules for what
is allowed but on guidelines that we
develop ourselves
uh over time and through negotiation
and this is just like real life where we
have roads and sidewalks and parks that
we all pay for and we all get to use
and in public there are many many
bastardly things that you can do
but you don't because you don't want to
be a dick and most of us are sensitive
to that
and to the like the communities agreed
upon standards of politeness
uh and we already have this in
javascript this is how we decided that
object.prototype was
that we were going to treat it as a dmz
and we've got people like doug crawford
who
writes emily post-like lists of do's and
don'ts
and we've got people like john resig who
rather rather than
rather than write it down further their
ideas of politeness through the code
they write and it's all great
and it's not the sort of thing oops
where's my pointer there we are
um we shouldn't run from this sort of
thing because it's a powerful force and
it makes the language better this
doesn't happen in java
where like the language itself outlaws
anything that anyone might consider rude
and in that sense it's a lot like
singapore
but javascript is a lot less
authoritarian
and more as a result more
adaptive to evolving customs i know all
this because i've seen it happen in the
ruby community
because ruby has has evolved quite a bit
in the last seven years
because of the influence of rails and
because near nearly everything is
possible in ruby itself
the language has evolved primarily
through the influence of community norms
um there are some of us who think that
taking ideas from other languages
is wrong somehow that it shows you're
stuck in a non-javascript mindset
i don't really buy into that because
ruby and javascript are remarkably
similar
they share a small talk influence
javascript took a detour through self
um which is a the small talk offshoot
that
introduced the idea of prototypal
inheritance but their design ideas are
otherwise very much in agreement
from the beginning rails took full
advantage of ruby's
dynamism rails is basically a collection
of dependencies and one of them is
called active support and it holds
all of rails extensions to ruby's
standard library
and it's got stuff like this so
because you can add stuff to the numeric
class
that's sort of the superclass of both
integers and floats you can
have a terse expressive syntax for
describing time spans and dates
in the future or the past or for
describing quantities of bytes or
megabytes
and i find that most people when they
when they see this think either holy
that's awesome
i would use that all the time or holy
that's ridiculous
please never show that to me again
but this is a less polarizing example um
so if you need to iterate over a
collection and call an instance method
on
on each item you can um you can do it
the first way
in ruby which is sort of the explicit
way of defining
defining a block which is basically a
function
or you can do it the second way
because active support defines a
coercion rule for converting a symbol
into
uh into a function much the same way
that there are implicit conversions
uh implicit coercions in javascript like
tostring and value of
and so active support to find one of
those coercion rules for four symbols
where one didn't exist before so this
didn't break anything
and was a really sort of concise way to
describe something that people needed to
do very often and so this was widely
regarded
in the ruby community as a good idea so
much so that it's actually now in the
in the language itself um you know and
all the major ruby engines implement it
natively
and it reminded me of something that
happened in javascript
way back in 2004 a swedish programmer
named daniel brockman wrote a white
paper about partial application in
javascript
and ways to rebind scope and the paper
takes us through several iterations
but we eventually end up with this and
as far as i know this was the first
appearance of function.prototype.bind
in the wild and apparently sam stevenson
stumbled upon it sometime later because
bind has been in prototype since the
very first version and if we look at the
old prototype 1.0 website we see
daniel's name
in the list of contributors
at first bind only rebounds rebound
scope that's all it did
both as defined in daniel's white paper
and as implemented in prototype by
prototype 1.4 it was rewritten to
support partial application
by passing extra arguments to the
original function
much like you would do with with call
so think about that and and the fact
that specs don't always get it right the
first time
we saw that with call and apply call was
great but it failed to address the case
where you need to pass some arguments
along but you might not know exactly how
many of them there are
um so we needed we needed to apply for
that case
um and so now bind is in the es5 spec
and it's certainly the case that the
spec
the spec probably would have gotten
around to implementing bind
even without its widespread use
it's not like this was an idea that
nobody would have thought of but i
wonder if they would have gotten it
right the first time
or would it would it have looked like
daniel's first version
the fact that we can define it and use
it in real world code
also lets us see what we might change
about it and that's a proving ground for
apis that specs
can't really compete with for me that's
the greatest value
of grassroots improvements to the
language
but back to ruby so i gave you two
examples of active support enhancements
one of them is hugely popular and the
other is still divisive
the drawback of social customs and code
is the occasional act of rudeness people
will write stupid code as they always do
but
their stupid code will sometimes get in
your way and vice versa
zed shaw is an infamous ex-rubist
he's primarily known for writing code
and yelling at people and he's very good
at both
and sometimes they run in parallel
and he's able to deliver impassioned
rants about good and bad code and
once he had a terrible time debugging an
issue that turned out to be caused by
someone else's
dumb monkey patch and he posted on
usenet about it because
again that's what usenet is for he
writes
not only does this code reopen a class
do something that could just as easily
be done with subclassing but the off the
author also turns off documentation
so that nobody knows about it so much
for principle of least surprise
this is more like principle of most
heinous arsenic injection
please think of the children before you
reopen their parent with a damn chainsaw
the web is awesome because it assigns
ideas permalinks and i can't tell you
how often
people answer ruby questions um
in news groups and on stack overflow and
and on forums by linking to
the chainsaw infanticide logger maneuver
it's one of the major contributors to
ruby's
current community standards of polite
core extensions
and polite monkey patching
i'm partial to a similar fable on
rubyforum.com
someone had asked about doing something
self-consciously clever with a
constructor so that
a certain method would always magically
get called at the end of
initialization and someone wrote
that may look good now but someone who's
debugging some code which depends on it
will hate you
and when you're debugging six months
from now you'll hate yourself if you
really want to do this put some real
effort into
into designing a clean api for it make
it obvious that you're putting a twist
on the
on the conventional method calling chain
document the api so it's obvious
in a coherent readily understandable way
don't slip a concrete dildo into
someone's box of fruit loops
they won't be happy with your morning
breakfast surprise
put the concrete dildo in a clearly
labeled box with instructions
then when someone encounters a problem
hey something is screwing me here
maybe it's the concrete dildo at least
they know to ask
um yehuda katz is a major figure
in both ruby's community and ours and he
said something interesting
recently in the comments of one of his
blog posts
it's occasionally the case that that a
core extension in active support
will conflict with a core extension in
another ruby library
and the commenter asked him why when
this happens
it's usually the other library that's
expected to change
and he replied with this and it makes
sense to me if generalized extensions to
built-ins
are a privilege we can choose to grant
that privilege to exactly one library
in order to minimize the risk of
conflict
in practice this is what the ruby
community has done rather than have a
bunch of libraries that try to enhance
the language
um they've standardized around active
support and practice
um and it gives us a sort of
uh uh
it gives us a way to go forward in
javascript i think um
make mental note of all the libraries
that you use on your website
and count how many of them try to
provide language extensions how many of
them extend built-ins if the answer is
more than one you've probably got a
problem
if the answer is exactly one
everything's fine if the answer is zero
then you should probably be defining
some
language language extensions yourself
or else you're putting plastic on a
couch like our grandparents used to do
so ruby has learned a few things from
these fights and they're all
applicable to the javascript community
as well first of all if your code
extends built-ins
make it plainly obvious to anyone either
reading the code
or reading the documentation it
shouldn't be a surprise
second because active support is a
collection of largely
separate language enhancements um it's
also useful that you can require just
parts of it
rather than the whole thing
and that minimizes the chance of
collisions
and yes you can monkey patch but do so
as a last resort
and in a way that ensures that you won't
break the method luckily there's a
strong
testing ethos in the ruby community
so when a library monkey patches
something it's usually got a crapload of
unit tests
to ensure that the method still works as
expected
but as i see it there are still two big
problems left that can't be solved in
modern day ruby and unfortunately both
of them are also applicable to
javascript
the first is the thing that we just
talked about
i can i can grant the privilege of
extending built-ins to one library but
only one
zachus's blog post mentions emmanuel
kant's test for
determining if an act is moral what if
everyone did it would it create chaos
um and despite the fact that that
frames best practices in terms of
morality
i think that's a legitimate question i
find this troubling
on one hand um it's a privilege that's
freely agreed upon between
the privileged library and the user
there's no coercion involved or anything
but it does start me off down a path of
picking and choosing my dependencies
based on which core extensions they rely
upon
for prototype this has been a problem um
there are cases where prototypes run
into con conflicts with other libraries
that extend built-ins
most notably ext and there's no easy way
around that and i don't want people to
have to choose between prototyping
something else
the other problem is related to that to
this when i use rails
it pulls in active support and all of
its core extensions
is it doing that for me or is it doing
that for rails
like does rails extend built-ins just so
rails can use
those built-in extensions or is it also
stuff that it thinks that i would find
useful
it's a bit of both but the point is that
once a library
requires a core extension it's out there
visible to everyone whether whether they
ask for it or not
so i've given the historical perspective
and that the language is evolving we're
getting tools to deal with some of this
stuff
is there any way we can extend built in
safely right now
like say we wanted to bring back
object.prototype that extend
in a less annoying fashion so we
couldn't write it like this
but we could do something like this es5
now let us
lets us define a property set its value
and mark it as non-innumerable
so we can prevent it from showing up in
four in four in loops so
our example from before seems to work
now um only twice
through the loop instead of three times
we might be tempted to
stop now and declare victory but um
there are a couple of other problems
what if i have an object with a key
called extend
i can't call my extend method on it the
way i want it's been shadowed
my property shadow's the one on the
prototype this is the problem with
having to use objects as hashes
and then there's this which is far
sneakier anything you add to
object.prototype
will be added to window or whatever your
global object is
and because it's the global scope any
unqualified reference to that identifier
will point to the global copy
as far as i know there's nothing you can
do about this either
this will happen even in strict mode and
as i understand it these issues are part
of the reason why all the new es5 stuff
is landing on objects rather than
object.prototype if we have
if we had
object.prototype.definedproperty
we'd have we'd be creating a global
defined property function also
so even in es5 there's no safe way to
extend object.prototype in the general
case
for other built-ins it's not so bad
because you don't have to worry about
key collisions because you're not using
those objects as
hashes if you're defining extensions for
an es5 only environment like node you
should seriously think about defining
all
those extensions as non-innumerable
if you're defining extensions in an
environment that may or may not have es5
stuff
it's not as simple prototype could
define all of its array extensions as
non-enumerable
in es5 environments but then we'd have a
weird situation where
those extensions would get enumerated in
some browsers but not in others
and i'm not sure that's progress um
but speaking of es5 only environments um
node is a homogeneous environment you
don't have to worry about that sort of
thing and it supports all the es5
awesomeness
so surely this is a safe place to extend
built-ins
um i saw that tootall nate released a
node timeline
library a few weeks back and it's a
perfect example of what i think node
should be doing with built-ins
it augments the built-in date object in
javascript to
uh to add support for time zones
so you required the library your date
object is enhanced and when you create
is enhanced and when you create a new
date it'll have methods for setting and
getting the time zone and once you set
the time zone
all date methods will take the time zone
into account when returning values
it's minimally invasive and highly
valuable it's adding three or four
methods to dates that are highly
unlikely
to conflict with anything
there's one more browser topic though
that we should talk about the browser
has always been
an uneven land landscape and
we've we've always had to deal with
varying capabilities across browsers
and the disparate the disparity will
only get broader now that we've got es5
so why not smooth it out back in the day
was
common to implement array the push
method on arrays or
apply on functions for browsers that
didn't support them
and there seems to be widespread
agreement that we should try to do this
for es5 which is a weird sort of thing
it's
it's sort of like the opposite of paving
the cow paths rather than rather than
take something that everybody's doing
and stand and standardize it we're
taking something that's
agreed to be standard in a future spec
and sort of like retconning it into a
into our existing narrative
but it's something that everybody seems
to be behind so here's a version of
object.keys
for es3 taken directly from the
mozilla developer center docs which are
great because
for any es5 method that's implementable
in es3
they will have the example
implementation right there on the page
prototype already had an object.keys
method
so we had to change it to conform to the
spec including throwing the type error
if you give it a non-object
so it technically broke backward
compatibility but the impact of the
change was minimal
likewise here's mdc's version of bind
it's very similar
to in behavior to the one in es5
um it's not quite identical there's a
lot of nuanced behavior
in the es5 version that we can't quite
replicate but it's all minor stuff
to get us started on the idea of safe
sensible built-in
extension i'm proposing the least
controversial idea i can think of
let's start depending on
function.prototype.bind
i would love to see this snippet of
javascript
become the world's most widely used
polyfill
let's treat it as the canonical
definitive way to bind scope in
javascript
now every library already has a way to
bind scope but that's
kind of the problem every library has
its own way of binding scope
i think we're talking about something
that's so basic to the understanding of
the language that it shouldn't be a
library function
new javascript users struggle mightily
with scope
it doesn't really help that each library
has a different way of doing it and a
lot of people i think just throw up
their hands and write var that equals
this
and just to be done with it
and i'm sure i'm biased but i've seen no
library function that can compete with
the terrorists and simplicity
of bind if i run into a scope issue if i
see that my callback isn't executing in
the scope i thought it would i can
just add dot bind this to the end of the
function and
and everything works so that's my
proposal
i think we should take that bind
polyfill and make sure it's pulled into
every website we make
prototype is going to complete its es5
conformance in the next
minor version we'll change our version
of bind to match the polyfill
and we'll do the same for the rest of
our collisions with built-in es5 methods
and this is part of the contract i think
if a method in your library ends up
getting standardized somehow make sure
your version agrees with the spec
and change it if it doesn't um even if
it breaks backward compatibility that
way you can take advantage of the more
performant native version
if it's there so we've done past and
present
and so let's take a look at what the
future holds
there are still a couple of large
problems that prevent us from extending
built-ins completely safely in
javascript
but class boxes are a new idea in
language development and by
a new idea i mean it's about eight years
old
but that's often how long it takes to go
from conception to implementation
um the aim is to bridge the gap between
classical module systems and
environments where everything is mutable
class boxes let me say i want to i want
to make these changes to existing
classes
and isolate those changes so that they
affect only me and nobody else
class boxes are finding their way into
ruby 2.0 there's a proposal and there's
even a patch for it and they're called
refinements instead of
class boxes because there are subtle
differences in semantics
but the idea is the same refinements
would mean that i could define some
awesome time extensions
like you know the ones that you hate and
i think are awesome
and i can import them into an arbitrary
lexical scope
here where we're importing them file
wide but i could just as easily import
them into a single class or a single
method
and then other people's code doesn't
have to see it at all
only lexical scopes that have imported
these refinements will see them
it's still not certain that this will
make it into ruby 2.0 but
the response has been very positive so
if it's good enough for ruby why not
javascript
for a long time i thought this kind of
thing had been explicitly ruled out as
part of the harmony compromise but
i was pleased to find out that i was
wrong
just last week there was a
there was a straw man posted to the
ecmascript wiki
called scoped object extensions
the usual caveats apply for straw men
but here's how it might work
uh so inside a module block you can use
an extension keyword
along with an object you want to class
box like number.prototype in this
example
and we're also giving that extension a
name so we can refer to it later
and we can add whatever we want to that
extension with our ordinary object
literal syntax
then again in any lexical scope we can
import these extensions
as we're doing here instead of inside of
a function
so we're able to say i want to use these
extensions here
just within this function but nowhere
else
this is the sort of thing that would
finally solve the outstanding issues
that prevent built-in extension from
being 100
safe so this is still a straw man which
means there's no guarantee it'll happen
but also but even if everyone agrees
this is a good idea it's
it's still it's too late for harmony um
so we're looking at es.next at the very
earliest
uh but the the silver lining is that
we've got
environments like node now where um
people can use things as soon as they're
implemented it's uh it's not like
uh clients that web development where
you have to wait like five or ten years
before a feature is why it's like is
widely deployed enough that you can
start using it
so i'm going to boldly predict that this
will be in the language someday
maybe a thousand years from now but but
someday um
i'm optimistic about it because i'm
tired of having these awesome features
that we can't use
uh and i eagerly await a time when we
can finally extend built-ins without the
traditional downsides at which point
hopefully
you know we'll we can stop having dumb
arguments about this and apologize to
each other for all the hurtful things
that we've said and
just get back to writing code um
that's all i've got uh we have time for
a couple questions i think so so the
question was that a lot of my examples
featured a sort of like domain-specific
language type syntax and and
and wondering whether uh built-in
extension was the way to address that
and um you know that's that
that's a valid point and i should i
shouldn't um
but i like i i don't think that my
examples necessarily
reflect like the breadth of of what
active support actually does with with
built-in extension
um i'm all i'm all for other types of
enhancements to support those those
those kinds of things
um like like the proxy objects that
we're getting in harmony and hopefully
something
that we'll replace with in a way that's
not as awful as with
so that we can do more dsl type stuff
all right if it's quick how would you
say the efforts of common js modules
relate to
your your proposal of a standard
polyfill of object upbind
com.js modules are are interesting
and this was something that i that i
that i cut out from the top because i
didn't really have time to
to address it um
yeah like if if i were writing a note
app
then like i imagine that i would have
some module that
that i pull in that would define
that would do all of my built-in
extension i mean that's that's the way
that i would do it personally
it's also the case that um there's
the node community is sort of
experimenting with the idea of running
modules in
in a sandbox where they can't even get
at your built-ins
um and i think i think that's in that's
an interesting dynamic that's going to
play
out over the next year or so
i think i mean it's such a such a tiny
piece of code that i think
that people should inject into into
their environment however they like
um all right i'm out of time but thank
you all
uh you know there are planes chris we
didn't have to take a wagon to oregon
you